우리 모두는 누군가 엿듣는 걱정 없이 개인 정보를 전달할 수 있어야 해요. 그런데 이걸 위한
완벽한 시스템을 설계하는 건 쉽지 않아요. 오늘 Qiskit in the Classroom 에피소드에서는
양자 키 분배라고 불리는 기술이 어떻게
도움이 되는지 이야기해 볼게요. Qiskit in the Classroom에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 이 시리즈에서는 양자
컴퓨팅 관련 대학 강의에서 접할 수 있는 주제들을 다뤄요. 각 영상에는 설명란에 링크된 인터랙티브 모듈이 있으니까
꼭 확인해 보세요. 오늘은 양자 암호학의 세계로 들어가 볼 거예요. 암호학은 안전한 통신을 위한
기술을 연구하는 학문이에요. 이건 우리 삶의 많은 부분에서 정말 중요해요. 웹사이트에 로그인할 때 비밀번호를 입력하거나,
디지털 결제를 하거나, 정부가 군사 기밀을 전송할 때도
모두 어떤 암호 프로토콜을 통해 이루어져서 도청자가 우리 비밀을 알 수 없게 해요. 그런데 여기에 긴장감이 있어요.
어떻게 하면 우리가 소통하길 원하는 사람은 메시지를 이해할 수 있게 하면서, 다른 누구도 이해하지 못하게 할 수 있을까요?
역사적으로 암호학자들은 메시지를 도청으로부터 최대한 안전하게 만들기 위해
다양한 프로토콜을 개발해 왔어요. 때로는 안전하게 소통하려는 두 당사자가 미리
어떤 코드에 합의하는데, 그게 너무 복잡해서 도청자가 해독하지 못하기를 바라는 거예요. 그런데
Alan Turing 같은 사람들과 전시 암호 해독가들이 보여줬듯이, 아무리 복잡한 코드도
해독될 수 있어요. 이상적으로는 아무런 패턴이 없어서
송신자와 수신자만 알고 있는 비밀 랜덤 키 없이는 도청자가 절대 이해할 수 없는
방식으로 암호화된 메시지를 보내고 싶어요. 그런데 그러면 새로운 취약점이 생겨요. 이 키를 어떻게 보내면서
아무도 가로채지 않는다는 걸 확신할 수 있을까요? 1984년에 Charles Bennett과 Jill Brassard가
quantum bit으로 키를 안전하게 전송하는 방법을 고안했는데, 지금은 BB84라고 불려요. 이 quantum
bit, 즉 qubit이 이 프로토콜을 가능하게 하는 핵심 특성은 불확정성 원리를 따른다는 거예요. 양자 시스템은
교란하지 않고는 측정할 수 없어요. 오늘은 간단한 암호 코드 예시부터 시작할 거예요. 그 다음에
양자 키 분배와 불확정성 원리가 어떻게 거의 해독 불가능한 암호화를
가능하게 하는지 보여드릴게요. BB84 프로토콜을 자세히 설명하고, 마지막으로 실제 양자
컴퓨터에서 실행해 볼 거예요. 먼저 크립토그램이라는 게임부터 시작해 봐요.
무작위처럼 보이는 문자 배열이 주어지는데, 영어의 패턴에 대한 지식을 활용해서
한 글자를 다른 글자로 대체해 메시지를 해독할 수 있어요. 예시를 볼게요. 이건
간단한 치환 암호를 사용한 비밀 메시지예요. 모든 R은 하나의 글자를, M은
다른 글자를 나타내는 식이에요. 직접 풀어보고 싶으시다면 지금 영상을 일시 정지하세요.
이 메시지는 시저 암호라는 아주 간단한 암호로 암호화됐는데,
알파벳을 일정 수만큼 이동시키는 방식으로, 이 경우에는 9칸이에요. A는 J가 되고, B는
K가 되고, C는 L이 되는 식이에요. 메시지가 길수록 패턴을 발견하기가
더 쉬워져요. 그래서 우리가 받은 것처럼 긴 메시지에서 시저 암호나 알파벳의 한 글자를
다른 글자로 치환하는 암호는 꽤 쉽게 해독돼요. 비밀 메시지를 더 안전하게 인코딩하는 방법은
일회용 패드예요. 일회용 패드를 사용하면 메시지의 각 글자마다 다른 이동값을 적용할 수 있어요.
친구에게 각 글자에 적용된 이동값을 알려주기만 하면 메시지를 해독할 수 있어요.
이 이동값 목록을 키 또는 패드라고 해요. 한 번 사용하고 버리기 때문에 일회용 패드라고 불려요.
두 번 이상 사용하면 패턴이 생겨서 암호화가 해독될 수 있어요. 일회용
패드 암호화에서는 암호화된 메시지와 키 각각은 그냥 무작위 문자열이에요. 그런데
두 개를 합치면 노이즈 속에서 비밀 메시지가 나타나요.
간단한 예시를 해볼게요. 제가 이미 친구에게 이 일회용 패드를 만들어 보냈다고 해요. 보통 이진수로 작성되죠.
그 다음에 "I love quantum"이라는 메시지를 보내고 싶어요. 그러면 메시지를
이렇게 일회용 패드를 사용해 인코딩해요. 먼저 메시지의 글자들을 이진수로 변환해요. A부터 Z까지 각 글자는
1부터 26까지의 숫자를 이진수로 나타낸 것에 해당해요. A는 0 0
0 1, B는 0 0 1
0, C는 0 0 1 1, 이런
식이에요. 그리고 공백은 그냥 전부 0이에요.
그러면 메시지는 이렇게 돼요. 메시지의 각 비트와 일회용 패드의 해당 비트 간에 XOR을 수행해서 메시지를 인코딩해요.
XOR을 본 적이 없다면, 배타적 논리합(exclusive or)의
약자예요. 두 비트의 XOR은 두 비트 중 하나만
1이면 1이 되고, 둘 다 0이거나 둘 다 1이면 0이 돼요. 그래서 인코딩된 메시지의 첫 번째 5비트 세트는
1 0
0 1 1이 돼요. 나머지 XOR은 직접 해보세요. 핵심은
이 메시지가 이제 아무런 패턴 없는 0과 1의 무작위 문자열이라는 거예요. 메시지를 암호화하는 데 사용한 일회용 패드가 없으면
완전히 해독 불가능해요. 그럼 지금까지 뭘 배웠나요? 어떤 암호화 방식은
다른 것보다 낫고, 어떤 건 암호화된 메시지에서 패턴을 찾는 똑똑한 사람이 추론할 수 있어요.
그런데 비밀 메시지의 각 글자를 다른 무작위 양으로 이동시키는 진정한 무작위 키는
메시지에 패턴이 없기 때문에 추론할 수 없어요. 이런 방식에서 유일한 취약점은
메시지를 암호화하는 데 사용된 키가 잘못된 사람의 손에 들어가지 않도록 하는 거예요. 바로 여기서 양자 키
분배가 등장해요. qubit을 사용해서 Bennett과 Brassard가 두 당사자가 키에 합의하면서
제3자가 몰래 엿듣지 않았다는 걸 합리적으로 확신할 수 있는 방법을 고안했어요. 이 BB84 프로토콜은 좀 복잡한데,
단계별로 살펴볼게요. 이 설명을 위해 우리의 오랜 친구 Alice와
Bob을 다시 불러올게요. 프로토콜은 Alice가 Bob에게 보낼 qubit 세트를 준비하는 것으로 시작돼요. 이 qubit들에는
두 사람이 공유할 일회용 패드 또는 키가 될 정보가 담겨 있어요. Alice는 먼저 같은 길이의 두 가지 무작위 시퀀스를 생성해요.
하나는 0과 1의 무작위 시퀀스이고, 다른 하나는 x와 z의 무작위 시퀀스로
qubit을 준비할 basis를 나타내요. 그런 다음 이 차트에 표시된 basis와 비트 값의 조합에 따라
각 qubit을 양자 상태로 준비해요. 비트가 0이고 basis가 z이면
qubit을 0 상태로 준비해요. 비트가 1이고 basis가 X이면 마이너스 상태로 준비해요. 이
basis와 양자 상태가 뭔지 잘 모르셔도 괜찮아요. 꼭 알아야 할 핵심은
각 basis에서의 측정은 항상 두 가지 가능한 결과만 나온다는 거예요. Z basis는 0 또는 1, X
basis는 플러스 또는 마이너스예요. Z basis에서 0 상태를 측정하면 항상 0이 나와요.
그런데 같은 상태를 x basis에서 측정하면 각각 50% 확률로
플러스 또는 마이너스의 무작위 결과가 나와요. Alice는 이런 식으로 qubit 문자열을 준비할 수 있는데, 여기가 무작위
0과 1의 문자열이고, 여기가 무작위 x와 z의 문자열이에요. 그녀의 두
시퀀스의 첫 번째 요소는 0과 x였어요. 그래서 첫 번째 qubit을 플러스 상태로 준비하는
식이에요. 모든 qubit 상태를 준비하면 Alice는 Bob에게 이 qubit들을 보내고, Bob은 각 qubit을 측정할 basis로 X와
Z 중에서 무작위로 선택해요. 그래서 이제 Bob의 선택과 측정을 나타내는 행을
차트에 추가해요. 여기 Bob의
측정과 basis 선택이 있어요. 그리고 여기 Alice가 보낸 qubit에 대한 그의 측정 결과가 있어요. 마지막으로 Bob은
Alice가 qubit을 준비할 때 사용한 것과 같은 표를 이용해 각 측정값을 비트로 변환할 수 있어요. 그가
0 또는 플러스 상태를 측정하면 비트 값 0을 할당해요. 1 또는 마이너스 상태를 측정하면
1을 넣어요. 그래서 Bob의 최종 비트 문자열은 이 마지막 행이에요.
Alice의 준비 단계와 Bob의 측정 단계의 basis가 일치하면, 그들의 비트도 일치한다는 걸 주목하세요.
그런데 Alice가 Z로 준비하고 Bob이 X로 측정하거나 그 반대이면,
Alice와 Bob의 해당 비트가 반드시 같지는 않아요. 그래서 두 사람이 일회용 패드용 비트 문자열에
합의하는 방법은 서로 전화해서 각 qubit에 어떤 basis를 사용했는지 알려주는 거예요.
basis가 일치하면 비트를 유지하고, 일치하지 않으면 버려요.
그래서 이 경우 Alice와 Bob은 0 0 1 0
0이라는 비트 문자열에 합의하게 돼요. 이 방식이 어떻게 들키지 않는 도청자로부터 보호할까요? 그럼 Eve라는 도청자가
Alice가 Bob에게 보내는 qubit을 가로챌 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 살펴볼게요. 그녀는 이 qubit들이 어떤 상태인지, Alice가
어떻게 준비했는지 몰라요. 그래서 불확정성 원리와 복제 불가 정리 덕분에 그녀는
Bob에게 전달할 qubit의 동일한 복사본을 만들 수 없어요. 만약 할 수 있다면
들키지 않고 도청할 수 있겠죠. 대신 그녀는 각 qubit을 측정할 basis를 추측하고, 측정한 다음,
Bob에게 보낼 새로운 위조 qubit 세트를 준비해요. Eve가 qubit에 대해 알아내려는 다른 더 교묘한 방법도 있지만,
어떤 것도 불확정성 원리를 피할 수 없어요.
그래서 이 간단한 도청 방법만 가정할게요. Alice의 준비, Eve의
가로채기, Bob의 최종 측정을 설명하는 차트가 있어요. 이제
Alice와 Bob이 전화로 basis를 비교할 때, 이 비트들을 키로 유지하기로 결정하겠지만
비트가 일치하지 않아요. 이건 Bob이 Alice의 원래 qubit이 아닌 Eve가 준비한 qubit을 측정하고 있기 때문이에요.
그들이 비트 문자열의 일부 비트를 서로 비교하면, 일부가 일치하지 않는 걸 보고
도청자가 있었을 거라고 판단해요. 그래서 Eve가 발각됐으니 Alice와 Bob은
비트 문자열을 버리고 프로토콜을 처음부터 다시 시작해요. 그런데 Eve가 도청하지 않았고, Alice와 Bob이 비교한
비트의 일부가 일치한다면, 비교하지 않은 나머지 비트들을
공유 키로 사용할 수 있어요. Alice와 Bob이 공유 키를 갖게 되면, Alice는 Bob에게 암호화된 메시지를 보낼 수 있고,
Bob만이 그 키로 메시지를 해독할 수 있어요. 프로토콜을 살펴봤으니 이제 양자
컴퓨터에서 시도해 볼게요. 이 실험에서 몇 가지 주의사항이 있어요. 첫째,
BB84는 Alice와 Bob이 서로 멀리 떨어져 있을 때만 실제로 유용해요. 우리가 하려는 실험에서는 Alice와
Bob이 같은 양자 칩 위에 있어요. 그래서 이 실험이 개인 정보 교환에는 유용하지 않겠지만,
BB84의 개념적 시연으로는 여전히 좋아요.
둘째, 실제 양자 컴퓨터에는 노이즈가 있어요. 그래서 Alice의 준비 basis와 Bob의 측정 basis가 일치하고
도청자가 없어도, 양자 컴퓨터의 오류로 인해 서로 다른 비트를 측정할 작은 가능성이 여전히 있어요.
도청자 여부를 확인하기 위해 비트 문자열을 비교할 때, 키 전체를 버리기 전에 어느 정도 오류에 대한 허용치가 필요해요.
도청자가 개입했다는 결론을 내리기 전에요. 이런 주의사항을 염두에 두고
도청자 없이 실험을 시작해 볼게요. 먼저 무작위로
각각 20비트씩 세 가지 비트 문자열을 생성해요. 첫 번째는 Alice의 초기 비트
문자열이에요. 두 번째는 Alice가 qubit을 준비할 basis 목록이에요.
여기서 0은 Z basis를, 1은 X basis를 나타내도록 했어요. 마지막 목록은
Bob이 각 qubit을 측정할 basis예요. 이 세 목록을 바탕으로 Alice의 준비와 Bob의 측정에 대한 지침이 담긴
circuit 다이어그램을 만들 수 있어요. 모든 qubit은 0 상태에서 시작해요. Alice가 Z basis로 qubit을 준비할 때,
0 상태는 아무것도 하지 않거나, 1 상태는 X로 표시된 파란 박스처럼 NOT 또는 X gate를 적용해요.
X basis로 준비할 때는 0을 플러스 상태로 바꾸는 Hadamard gate를 적용하거나,
마이너스 상태를 준비하려면 NOT gate에 이어 Hadamard를 적용해요. 그런 다음 Bob에게 qubit을 보내요. circuit의 다음 박스 세트는
Bob의 측정을 나타내요. Z basis로 측정하려면 더 이상 gate를 적용할 필요가 없어요.
그냥 측정하면 되는데, 이 회색 박스들로 표시돼요. X basis로 측정하려면 먼저 Hadamard를 적용하고
그 다음 측정해요. 이 circuit을 Qiskit runtime primitive sampler로 실행할 거예요. 출력 결과는 Bob의 비트
문자열 측정값이에요. 그러면 Bob의 비트 문자열을 Alice의 초기 비트 문자열과 비교하면서 basis가 일치하지 않는 비트는 버려요.
그러면 두 사람이 같은 키를 얻는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이건 실제 하드웨어이기 때문에 가끔 일치해야 하는 비트가 일치하지 않을 수 있어요. 이 경우에는 모든
비트가 일치하지만 직접 다시 실행하면 오류가 생길 수 있어요. 하지만 정확도가 1에 가깝기만 하면
Alice와 Bob은 도청자가 없었다고 합리적으로 확신할 수 있어요. 이제 Eve가 qubit을 가로채면 어떻게 되는지 살펴볼게요.
이제 두 개의 circuit이 있어요. 첫 번째는 Alice의 준비와 Eve의 가로채기 및
측정을 보여줘요. 다음은 Eve의 위조 qubit 준비와 Bob의 측정을 보여줘요.
이전처럼 이 circuit들을 실행하고, Alice와 Bob이 비트 문자열을
비교했을 때 어떻게 되는지 볼 수 있어요. 이번에는 정확도가 6이 반복되는 값이 나와요. 이건
양자 컴퓨터의 노이즈로 설명할 수 있는 것보다 훨씬 낮아요. 그래서 Eve가 도청하고 있었다는 결론을 내려요. 양자 컴퓨팅은
어려운 문제를 해결할 가능성으로 잘 알려져 있고 종종 과대 광고되기도 해요. 그런데 양자 통신과 암호학은
이 분야에서 양자가 제공할 수 있는 잠재력이 똑같이 중요하고 흥미로운데도
훨씬 적은 관심을 받는 경우가 많아요. 오늘은 탐지되지 않는 도청에 사실상 면역인 최초로 발견된 양자 키 분배 프로토콜에 대해 이야기했어요.
양자로 인증된 키로 해독 불가능한 코드를 보내는 걸 직접 해보고 싶다면,
설명란에 링크된 모듈로 이동하세요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요. 다음에 또 만나요.